[Music]
when I play games on my phone I turn the
volume way up because it confuses my cat
my dog hates when I use her as a pillow
but we'll always use me as one I'm sure
my head is not that heavy
hi dog is scared of my vibrator so when
she bugs me I chase her around the house
with it all sometimes I make strange
obnoxious noises just to annoy my cats
my dog hates when I have wet hair he
looks at me like I'm really offending
my dog nose when I'm taking a pic of him
and he hates it I torture my dog by
eating a cheeseburger really slow she
stares at me the whole time my cat gets
annoyed when I laugh and it's weirdly
hilarious and adorable when I can't
sleep I bother my dog to make sure she
stays awake it's not fair that she gets
to sleep when I can't i torture my dog
by putting him in a room with the
see-through door and petting my other
dog right in front of him he hates it
and I know I'm a bad person that it's
funny i watch musicals with my dog and
sing to her she hates it I've started
setting alarms around 3:00 and 4:00 a.m.
just to get up and wake up and annoy my
cat he hates me and wakes me up around
8:00 and 9:00 every morning
Oh
[Music]